join my dango roki block my night all
day should we wrap this [ __ ] up in fun
I want everybody to know we didn't talk
about fights at all okay you know why'd
you okay let's go over all I said was a
bunch of you feel like drained deranged
remainder Rhonda beam should have one or
do you think that she should have been
deducted points
she should be up she worse cases should
have been a draw I think the right thing
to do was Holly should've won even
deduct on what you have to deduct those
points and I think even Germain realized
that when she goes I'll give Holly
rematch right away cuz tainted she's
like I'm not a dirty fighter like she
knows what she did was [ __ ] up only
won that fight you think well Holly
definitely got the only legit knockdown
you know she got that she landed that
question mark kick that was beautiful
beautiful you hid it behind that older
came over the top playing I gave
probably the with rock there on control
let she landed more like kicks and she
had been only significant striking the
like that big stress no what about like
Germaine de random II did more damage
when she connected but she didn't
connect as much but then Holly did do
more damage in two instances one with
the question mark kick in another time
she dropped it with a straight left yes
that was one of the best punches of the
fight and that was in the fight thing
was the fourth round that's round with
it might benefit yeah she dropped her
and it was up it was a big moment so you
could say that that round and the head
kick round two different rounds or both
easily ten eight right you drop someone
drop someone was not ten a you don't
think so that was I knew halogens and
his new rule not the new rule eternity
which one which ones up bounce ahead no
no no no he said herself she was nasty
come Center sub screws days and there's
a picture of it on Mike Winkeljohn Zoar
Jackson Winkle sin John's um Instagram
account we see how well it connected yes
it's over the top it's just Shinda
dongjun she's wonderful
she went down from that that was legit
but Holly almost kicked in the face
while she was down yeah I don't know
them she might have you're allowed to
kick him in the chest Oh what's
interesting is like if she saw that her
hands were down she could have just
changed the angle a little bit and hit
her he or she has the skill to do that's
a good rule or a bad rule I think the
new one-handed rule is perfect I think
that's perfect so what does that were
one hands down you can still kick them
but if two hands make it yes well do
it's one hand
comes up you can kick him in the face
okay but don't you think I think to get
rid of my gal geing hitting after the
bell and leaving only kicks there's zero
tolerance tolerance policy where if it
happens we gotta duck the point hundred
posts not up to the rest anymore right
his reps don't want to change outcome of
the fight so they're so scared to deduct
a point what she did the Holly is
ridiculous she hit him wait why she's
been already too many fights she hit her
so hard it changed outcome of the fight
yes Chan Ho hocked it won she rocked it
with a giant right hand at the end of
the bell and it was bad it was bad to
the point where we all went oh like
Daniel Cormier was next to me horrible
so the first time I did a commentary
with Cormier and an anti click the three
of us together it was really good
chromate is great it was interesting
because it all depends what kind of
judge you got judging the fight but some
some judges would look at it the way you
guys are looking at based on what you
guys said and some would say the room
and then someone said yeah and then once
others would look at it like okay holly
was trying to take her down look like
she was avoiding the standup couldn't
take her down she had her against the
cage it was like some judges would look
at that as mm she doesn't want to fight
standing and she's not able to get the
fight to the ground she's kind of just
holding against the cage for safety some
people look at that as losing around and
not winning around you you know it's
ridiculous don't like to get freaked off
the jungle is ridiculous she wants to
get free and she can't get free them
Holly's holding her against the world
English oh my god well that'd be the
only well that's a rule that's the only
ways I was given how they judge a fight
that's always to judge a fight the
problem is is that that referee didn't
want to change the outcome of the fight
to show scared of the backlash they
don't they don't do it so you need to
take that power out of their hands ago
it's that sorry with separating people
when they were clinching there's a lot
of weird on the more on the New York
should not always be hair you can't
believe what you just said it I'm
surprised they let him even do that
title fight you have to it's New York
State New York State is going to appoint
their own referees in a certain amount
of fights and I don't know how many I
don't know how it works I don't know
what the agreement is but that's often
the case when you go into State athletic
commissions your Marcie Herb Dean I know
yeah that guy they made a vile evil beam
you have tips from the battacor McCarthy
or herb Dean come out and have make a
statement that John McCarthy said they
should issued a warning
right away like a strict warning on that
first one which I disagree with and he
goes on the second when I was to the
point they should take your point right
away and yeah I agree I agree for
absolutely the second one but I think
the first one was so egregious bad crap
good combo yeah well sir I'm not to take
the point I'm just not buying that that
you know like I get the heat of the
moment you can't let that happen
I get that you're in the heat of the
moment you want to kill and destroy and
you're Germaine Duran to me and you got
46 and oh and muy Thai and you're a
ten-time muy Tai Chan because you're a
[ __ ] killer she's a killer man and
that's what she is but there's a rule
not when the rule is the rule you know
you know what's going on you know what's
going on you've been in 46 before that
never did that so all of a sudden you're
doing it's the heat of the moment he
immediately met twice immediate rematch
that one $45 [ __ ] any though I would say
you have to have immediate Riva have to
but germane to random II look everybody
knows that cyborgs looming in the
background you know cyborgs always going
to be there there's no winner in this I
mean Holly should have won but yuck like
cyborg Nix enjoy that yeah it's going to
be really no winner it's going to be
really interesting to see what the
choice is
well nothing this rate to a rematch or
whether or not they let cyborg 545 a
nightmare for her suck down to no 40 is
she's done 45 million times not easy
here's the deal as you get older and you
do it more often your body resists it
more and more and more and the fact that
they make her I still maintain to this
day they should have never asked her to
go to 140
they should never been trying to get her
to 135 they should have just like either
have a featherweight division or don't
she said she could do it though she said
he met wasn't she's like yeah we can do
it so that's what I cool man there's so
many fighters who drop down a couple
weight class that's a normal thing in
any many sobei she's no big brother you
get smaller yeah you got smaller people
that 45:40 gonna do a class she can make
45 she's done it before but even now I
guess people get older again like
there's a lot of fighters it gets
tougher and tough and I can't do it
anymore
[Music]